e aí olha que assistiu ao canal tudo com
vocês estão aqui hoje com que ela morou
dois anos ea gente vai falar aqui sobre
o assunto bem legal bem bacana bem
interessante para você se divertir de
montão com essa turminha que é do
barulho
eu viajo muito que todo mundo viaja
muito e onde já foi webber manaus nexo
um carro e já fui lá em fortaleza já não
deixa o melhor foi ronaldo fugiu ronaldo
esse frio
muito obrigado todo lugar que a gente
vai pessoas falam diferentes já deu por
exemplo aqui e tem choque muito grande
aqui em são paulo que foi um vinho onde
é que eles falam todas antes de toda
falha mas viu é e falar pra você fala
assim eu já está chegando aí ele viu que
eu nem se ganha j chegando ainda que o
brasil está a outra planta chega aqui é
tapioca que aqui é tapioca é o aparelho
já feita né se com lalá tapioca é a
farinha que você usa para fazer o beijo
que quer fazer o quê beijo beijo beijo é
a pior actor liam em casa chega a partir
do papel que ela teve uma falha você
ande não é fácil
veja aqui o teu beijo beijo que aqui o
tiozinho de 250 sp joão é um parece ter
percebido uma massa que com certeza não
está pior que ela ligou para o nosso bem
o futuro assim que se fala é crocante
conhece jornada tipo nada ficou em 51 em
sua barriga pesadas
sou um pouco óbvia júri popular beijo e
é feito da tapioca farinha de tapioca
que falar que você fala faria de que a
gente chama ele foi campeão mas quando
alguém fala de tapioca já campeonato
onde já não lá a pior que você vai é a
farinha é você pega tapioca o botafogo
está bem junto do hotel você não vai
fazendo ao cm a farinha
olha eu acho que se você quiser comprar
na troca como chama tapioca minha mulher
que j pela então vejo é o beijo não é é
a linha não é só ontem o beijo é o beijo
é sempre um jogo de semifinal necessita
ganhar um notebook o sistema vai passar
fome na campanha ele se aliou viagem eu
tenho que perguntar pro pessoal do lugar
um palavrão do lugar não é isso aí eu
não sou eu em balanço que a uefa que na
hora vem mas empate desenrolar bronze
até o final de 2011 ou aceitavam lambada
uma coisa que é por exemplo em recife e
se uma pessoa quer tomar cuidado com
pessoas não tava com graça tabaco uma
pessoa idiota
achei muito bom grande na aqui tava
dando certo não é deus equipes vençam
essa carinha tabaco da bahia tabaco não
não segunda ela tava porque tabaco lá
onde eu moro tabaco último setor é meu
eu sempre estava tudo em nossa mente
pois é aí lá em recife estava grande do
sul e de outros antigos e se eu faço
muita piada toda hora engraçado a estava
muito tabaco não se esgotam assim uma
vez meu colega o gabriel no canal por
isso é ele foi lá em nossa europa ea
minha mudança que ela foi meio sem graça
teria ele falou ficar é muito tabaco nem
todo mundo falou que eu não sei não me
sinto lesado como se ela tivesse humana
tivesse olhando a grana é uma loucura
que foi já estava com não pessoa de
ottawa alegre a água não saiu
eu vou ficar aí só tem no sul também que
o pãozinho na época a cpi vai assistir
novela da hcb o senhor é mesmo isso não
seria um cacetinhos na praça tinha lá e
nós lhe ozzy em curitiba ninguém fao
seja vina e não eles querem com isso no
brasil é mais contida porque eu saí no
mma hoje papa e em são paulo em curitiba
e salsicha é vina fim na hora fala que
eu fiquei mal cara olhando para alugar
locar é muito tempo né é uma cara
cabreira é uma cabrio é uma cara o cara
tá fazendo um mock ele é nossa é bom
legal que é muito legal ter ligado o
local foi muito esperto que cada um tem
nada que o tempo já só objetivo não vai
usar ainda levou uma causa é ainda não
sei qual a razão é que estava acusada
que você pensa não tabaco tabaco a
macumba
quando penso em tomar que eu penso em um
charuto por isso falei com ele porque
ele mesmo tomar
o meu nome mil meu povo isso de manhã
porque ela chama pinta de piro é minha
mãe e eu fui eu quem domingo é de ir lá
em nordeste eu piro que gosta do
nordeste é mais agressiva tipo [ __ ] rola
pauta e ana é mais o tinha mais um ano
numa ronda em que ainda não têm data
pela pior seca não pergunta giro
conhecido de cá um problema problema
semelhante já caminha tchau meu sotaque
não sotaque carioca e tem um pouco
daquele as pessoas eu acho que é melhor
a cobra eu acho que tirando onda com a
tua casa então por que não pode falar
qualquer coisa pode ser assim tipo de
ficar rua para fazer um pouco espantado
como se fosse bem sim mais interessante
o carioca tem dois tipos de southwark
por exemplo nem fala às pessoas o que
falar
as pessoas não querem o xuxa project
tiger tempo você falar a pessoa é
exatamente na adesão a essa daí eu era
andré roulet tem último leque sair aí
parceiro pessoa chegar pessoa
preconceito está que rola também em são
paulo porque lá em são paulo no centro a
gente vai pra não ficar atrás vai
colocar peso como engraçado os
resultados ea gente aí nossa equipa
jogava de baixo passando a palavra
engraçado também aqui tipo assim quando
eu vou para um lugar que as pessoas
esperam que o nordeste inteiro fala do
mesmo jeito e às vezes uma com guy a
pessoa se decepciona o que eu não falo
já que ela quer que eu falo que fazem
fala tem ódio futebol tipo eu não vi
alguém no teu tenho um pé na bunda quer
ter os carros parecem sábio não sei não
sei explicar o cara fala num no ritmo é
você falou assim eu acho que eu acho a
gente que mora em pernambuco a chamei
cantado
ele fala tanto melhor
um sotaque eu gosto do sul eu fui
portalegre mano é muito engraçado é que
eu não vou ser mais macro é de vocês
nunca afinal porta em porta
aliás tema que a gente usa é feliz ainda
aqui com o pessoal do sul e fala pode
crê pode precisar de alguma coisa me faz
falta é brincadeira
lá é muito mais não abordar isso não
pode cair no começo de uma frase de seu
centenário
a mulher ouviu o gaciba de quem não é
você é muito legal flamengo é bem grande
não quero falar ainda mandou que eu
posso treinar lá eu sei que já fui mas
não posso dizer a vocês que já falou
fora tipo 1 fora do brasil lá é
diferente também lugar não sair pra lá
treinar eles uma vizinha mas tem o sus
nos carros e ônibus caipira me encanta
eu tenho mais vivência eu visitei não
tem muitos lugares não mas percebendo
jardim aqui não disse ana que eles usam
que urbanas problema do dancinha dos
patos até aí vamos buscar até aquele
sotaque bem caipira que eu seria o
interior de são paulo que foi o interior
né
lá eu já vi que tipo assim eu escutei
uns rap americano e tal aí eu vou lá não
ver a letra do rep
eu vejo também tem muita no tejo e na
leitura das mudas palavra também é tipo
mais negro bola mania já que ele é bem
bonita para rimar cabeça mais uma vez
não falhou qualquer erro agora não doeu
muito e meu irmão vai ver a letra afirma
chico uma linguagem que fala tão
parecida
é um jeito mais fácil é que eles têm lá
até ganha uma coisa que achei muito tem
muita gente que tem preconceito com o
estádio lotado aqui o meu todo mundo de
futebol eu fico pensando se houvesse
preconceito em brasília onde está toda
raça tá lá em brasília imaginou ao invés
do sul carlos galera
barbano a junto lá aportam outro fala
portão outro fala italiano pela desgraça
do brasil ele funciona nem sempre quem
tem o seu tempo que falar não tem
sotaque então manter mesmo exemplo
carioca fala eu tenho um sotaque mano
tem gente nova como tem gente que é mais
neutro taiwan
ai ai ai que estava neutralizada e quero
que o meu tudo louco é um cara em uma
casa e não vou ver ela isso é um outro
agente não tem nenhum problema em si do
que o que a gente fazer isso acham esse
cara que fala alemão não pô o cara que
tava 11 falar aos o cara está lá no acre
lançou um vídeo diferente no rio que o
cara daqui vai ouvir o sotaque saída
imagina coisa sair e voltar aqui está
legal também de minas o maior tsunami é
bem vindo
o dinheiro é tudo meu é meu que não haja
uma hora a mais na conta só isso é muito
legal de curitiba também muito forte
tanto do tipo t foi dia de curitiba
igual atendente leite que ontem não é um
entre hillary e pernambuco já é mais
digno de nota é nosso é doida de lá não
tive esse prazer brasil é sabido que o
painel também a nossa feijoada sem eu
tenho sempre tem aquela que tem um lugar
só então um país é mais diversificado
com nossa finitude sotaque com certeza
vai querer ser mais turistas mais de um
povo tão miscigenada taxa de filmes é o
chinês eo resultado é esse outro humano
essa etapa pode crer se você tem terreno
pode crer em botucatu que eles vão
comprar um plano 2010 em ottawa com
chineses têm morado na boca um cara de
pernambuco vai morar na china então mais
sentido nordeste que a gente vai pra um
vai estar diferente passa uma semana já
volta consultado em 2000 eu mesmo já
passei uma semana em minas eu volto já
sentindo que eu tô falando no ritmo do
menino já aqui eu já tenho pronto no dia
de seu irmão é ver a noiva empolgada
tipo a que eles falam que ele é legal a
gente em tal lugar de fala aí vira
agente então o round neca o verão muito
menor afirma viu que terá o que admira
sua maneira
o jogo então só uma coisa do cabelo é
abreu vai ficar a cabeça espelham eu
queria ficar puto na cara para manter o
cabelo chicago está a encetar conrado
caranha lá crescenta cabreira que a
cidade fosse um cara eu to me emprestou
eu prestei um drama para o time perde
não falam que eu tocava estádio
exatamente já fez pela cabeça é esperto
não vi jenson button da brawn não foi
capaz de parar de lutar pode pagar um
pai pode ir com ele até pode passar sem
falar com o pedreiro que você não pode
parar pode se machucar ao pai de rachel
arrastão ou o meu rasteiro
o homem é também o que mais tem aqui é
diferente nós ninguém vai entender nada
de sibuyan legal muito mais no brasil
entende o que o nosso time vem
discutindo família japonesa não
começaram e o são paulo acha que eu sou
eu imaginava onde você acham japão disse
para a gente vai faltar lugar celulares
no ano novo aqui lá a gente fala lá onde
eu moro porque lá é por exemplo o
nordeste o piauí inteiro que um pulmão
de humor agora quer teresina e fala
muito um com 16 que eles não sei quanto
tempo alguma coisa deu errado para mim
com um tapa na face à não saiu do lugar
não conseguirá ou 16 primeira parada
também é que também isolada
meu namorado é uma coisa típica mulher
um impacto tão antigo assim um carro
bateu no barranco e um carro bateu
parada não a gente não são bem assim não
tenho títulos ganhou muita grana smtu vá
surpresa meu pai meu nome é fama do
estado a maioria nem sabe a parada é uma
surpresa que quase nunca foi pressionado
com o que não viram que a gente fala
alguma coisa na hora de show eu estouro
é melhor textura muito na pele ano em
pernambuco
caramba carambolas a nossa
a galera é o seguinte eu quero que você
comente aqui embaixo é um dinheiro que
você acha muito estranha o que você acha
que a gente aqui não vai entender é aí
na sua cidade no seu estado não se
comenta em baixa e também dá aquele lá e
que nem naquele vídeo que você daquele
líquido de volta aqui nesse vídeo tá
40.000 a 50.000 light fica de mata fazer
o próximo vídeo e se esquece de curtir
as paradas que está aqui na descrição do
vídeo todo mundo ninguém vê nessas
coisas boas a inscrição não é importante
o mal nesta manhã a menina quer paulo
contendo
o balanço não não sou um cara é o cara
fiel à cultura nasce um pouco seu palco
gostei
você vê as partes da ia trocando cauê
canaleta a página dele é pai no carro ea
minha parte aqui na descrição do vídeo
tem que ler mais a galera eu já vi que a
galera um público não é ciúme não viu no
passado eu abri o vídeo com uma agulha 9
os principais comentários todos é o
mauro é o nome da mãe não sendo que a
primeira pessoa perguntou ele vai
primeiro nos comentários outra pessoa
respondeu tá lá o nome da música o cara
pergunta outro perguntou também mas é
isso pergunta responde a todo mundo não
se abaixar para a música interessante
vai ter outras pessoas não eu caí em
cima assim e aí que eu já saí o vídeo
dessa semana falando que se encantou com
o dia 29 o tubo cuba devia movimento é
por isso que eu peço a você fala em
seguir no instagram me seguir no
facebook me seguir no twitter quem não
tem como é possível em três coisas você
vai aprender o vídeo às vezes eu acabei
de enviar o vídeo cada pergunta é quem
vídeo novo colega meu caso cada pergunta
no vídeo novo quando vai terminar
acontece isso vai ou não vai ter de novo
kaká me emocionar pois é isso aí galera
muito obrigado sem curtir e se viu até
aqui é nós falou